hier encore vous étiez prêt à réduire de
45 millions d'euros le budget des
chambres d'agriculture avant que
l'amendement les républicains de fabrice
bras soutenu par la majorité et une
partie par l'opposition il partait
majorité ne vous fasse reculer
quel est donc votre logique comptable
sur la question des produits
phytosanitaires
vous définissez des trajectoires vous
annoncer la fin du glyphosate pour 2021
la pression est maximale sur les
agriculteurs mais rien pas un neurone
figure dans votre budget sur le placer
partie du glyphosate l'accompagnement de
la recherche d'alternatives ou
l'investissement dans des solutions
mécaniques
je vous demande de mettre sur la table
un budget dédié pour les cultures en
situation impasse vous nous avez fait
naître beaucoup d'espoirs vous nous avez
parlé la montée en gamme
la seule montée en gamme qu'ont vu les
agriculteurs ce sont des contraintes
supplémentaires
ce sont des charges supplémentaires ce
sont 80 intrusion dans des élevages
démontrant la maltraitance des animaux
vous avez dit les acteurs n'ont pas eu
le fruit de cette loi et galim calé vous
répondre aux agriculteurs à qui vous
avez fait naître autant d'espoir les
dérives communautaires de certains
employés de service public exposées sont
alarmantes par la bien conscience des
élites des signes évidents de
radicalisation dans ces services sont
tus c'est même le mot radicalisation qui
fait peur on n'ose pas désigner l'ennemi
alors que nous sommes en lutte contre
l'islamisme politique comme l'a dit
bruno retailleau le communautarisme
prépare le terreau des vocations
jihadistes de demain à chaque problème
l'exécutif tempête nous sommes devenus
coutumiers de ces indécisions permanente
là comme dans bien des domaines vous
mener une politique recentralisatrice
qui oblige les territoires on l'a
constaté avec votre passage en force sur
les 80 km heure au mépris des habitants
des territoires ruraux
on l'a constaté avec la hausse
insupportable des taxes sur les
carburants caps ont plombé le pouvoir
d'achat des français
on l'a constaté avec l'ignoble cabale de
dénigrement des mères
et l'odieux hashtag balance qu'en mer on
le constate encore hélas avec le budget
que vous souhaitez nous faire voter tout
à l'heure et qui constitue une véritable
nationalisation des impôts locaux
votre suppression populis de la taxe
d'habitation entraîne des transferts de
dotation en cascade et prépare une
invraisemblable usine à gaz dont les
principaux perdants seront les communes
et surtout les départements dans le
quotidien des habitants sur les
territoires ruraux il est actuellement
nombre de sujets qui amplifie le
sentiment d'abandon par l'état et les
pouvoirs publics
c'est irritant pour reprendre un terme
cher à sébastien lecornu sont nombreux
retrait des services de l'ade et des fip
fermetures de classes manque d' avs pour
les enfants constructibilité de plus en
plus restrictive baisse de la detr pour
cofinancer les projets des collectivités
démographie médicale alarmante
la litanie est longue et les exemples ne
manquent pas
la réunion enregistrée en 2012 notamment
une première baisse de l'emploi salarié
de 3400 emplois et donc une augmentation
du chômage de plus de 2% par rapport à
le pouvoir d'achat ne cesse de diminuer
avec le prêt la reprise de l'inflation
après quatre années de stabilité
les revenus des entreprises de la
filière d'école chute de 9 5% et enfin
le logement n'a jamais été on n'a jamais
aussi peu construit notamment depuis dix
est-ce que nous pouvons compter sur vous
pour que les arbitrages que vous ferez
dans le plf lps fss soit plus favorable
à l'outre-mer en 2020 et qu' à
l'évidence les chiffres que vous nous
avez proposé soit plus à l'auteur de no
attendre la taxe sur les paris sportifs
que vous avez refusé de déplafonner pour
donner des moyens supplémentaires à l'
agence nationale du sport sur la
question questions sur la forme d'abord
sur la manoeuvre employés puisque battu
battu à la régulière sur un amendement
vous êtes revenu au fond de la nuit sur
le vote de notre assemblée finalement
finalement quand ça quand ça vous
dérange quand le quand le vote n'est pas
favorable on revote plus tard avec moins
de monde et en prévenant surtout à la
dernière minute chacun chacun jugera
question sur le fond ensuite vous avez
supprimé des moyens attendus pour aider
le monde sportif et le développement des
pratiques sportives pour aider les
collectivités locales pour investir pour
les clubs pour les pratiquants pour les
équipements sportifs sans léser l'état
difficultés récurrentes d'organisation
de la sncf retards réguliers
mécontentement des usagers mais aussi
des agents qui va croissant par ailleurs
la prise en otages des passagers n'est
pas forcément la meilleure solution
la sncf fonctionne mal les raisons sont
multiples et la réforme
malheureusement ni rien changé
[Musique]